is michelle wolf a muslim now for muslim
four four is she full full so
interesting yeah but you've seen it the
long dresses and the and the head
coverings please tell me you're joking
no i'm not i'm just asking you
i do not know this michelle is a
brilliant joke writer yeah i believe she
might be full muslim and that's great i
love it i love that culture i love quiet
women and men who smoke and are gay kind
of a little yes but also i was just
asking if you heard that i know i'm
proud i'm proud of her i i'm all there's
like an email that goes around when they
get one over and yeah
i'm i i didn't get that no i could be
wrong yeah i might be wrong but there
are photos is there a better person to
not talk as much out loud
she has a voice
she was yeah the ideas are good if she
was in riyadh it would be
yeah walk around right keep walking yeah
but it's interesting this is quiet it's
the thing about comics we all know each
other as comics and then we forget we're
people
and then when people do things that
people do which is like convert to
religion or whatever right you're
surprised yeah but a voice is a choice
perhaps a little you know like you can
choose to lean in or lean out and it's
it's a choice like i lived in spain i
didn't speak with an english accent i
spoke with a spanish accent because i
made an effort that's true to care about
the people around me you love italy you
just got back with your wife you love
these areas
well i mean
you can't do 30 minutes on michelle
wolfe
uh this is more pressing she's gotten in
two years yes the thing is
the thing is i was just curious i'm
curious i like islam i like me too um uh
you love italy with the wife inshallah
i hope you had an amazing year i hope
you got some great gifts me too this is
great um yeah in italy how is the pizza
is it is it is it random that like a
girl with that voice dated the guy whose
name is most deaf well i think he's the
reason for the conversion
most death there we go yeah yeah
interesting you have to be all deaf to
deal with that
yeah but
most isn't most of us it works that'll
be all
um
okay we're gonna look for reason
yeah okay italy pizza
why like it it's so amazing
i question italians that moved here i
know yeah have you spent time
never i want to go tim i should go
i know it's the map i'm like the food
it's everything's beautiful no no it's
it's what you like i know it's
everything's lovely you you appreciate
yes people who have figured out things
that's right especially
life that's right and who spent
years trying to figure it out figuring
out warping a culture that's right like
wasp culture yes
is beautiful yes you go to the [__]
what is it polo bar over on like 57th
street whatever it is everything's
worked out that's right and we know
we're putting on costumes that's right
it's like we're in [__] venice
but it works and it's great and it's
comfortable and we love it right and
italy has done that with every aspect of
life yeah i'm i'm excited man like i
want to go and i know that i want to
take you yeah i'm being honest i would
like to be taken and
i will take you yeah please i'm gonna i
would love to you want to be taken bro i
will submit myself
to your financial whims to take me to
italy you you're the guy with the homes
i want to go
um i want to go badly i mean this
sincerely yeah i think you would [__]
love it and i think they're like they're
little pockets for everything that you
could enjoy like if you want some like
like i was i don't love uh [__] capri
there's a place capri right right and
it's beautiful it's awesome but it's
like um
it's a little like uh
it for me that's it it it's a little bit
too uh commercial i don't wanna say
commercialized like um
look how big my yacht is look right what
is that what what would you call that
it's a little miami it's a little miami
to miami yeah for sure but at the same
time l.a too it's a little l.a but it's
like look at me look what i can buy look
right the cool thing i liked about
amalfi is it wasn't that yes right it's
like
i will enjoy this life and i don't care
if you are noticing me yeah it doesn't
matter yeah if you if you notice what
i'm doing great if not we don't care and
like it was cool to be at a hotel
because that's real confidence exactly
that's real confidence there's something
cool about that old money is cooler than
new money why because there's a there's
a mystery to it yes there's a mystery to
a guy that drives a beat-up car to a
massive estate there's a mystery to
people you know because the mystery is
why do you have confidence and people
don't have confidence right it's it's
why do you have confidence and then why
don't you care about what i think about
you yes because that's the currency that
runs the world yes so how have you opted
out yes how did you opt out of that
you're all ugly yeah real rich people
are gross they're inbred
they're they're they're very interesting
look they're like strange looking none
of them are hot hot people are state
schools right state school ucsb yeah not
even private like some private but like
a hot state school a university like a
you know a hot state school yes [__]
basketball players always going to be
better looking than a [__] harvard
coder
but that that that you know as nick
mullen once brilliantly said inbred
syphilitic boy king
aesthetic of rich people of like kind of
malnourished weirdly put together uh
there's something so odd about it and
and they they do seem some of them like
they are another species yeah they might
be yeah but they understand life a
little bit yeah and they figured it out
and it's like while every one of these
billionaires like if they actually get
it yeah if they're not still trying to
like get the acceptance if they actually
get like right
they go to [__] montana and they just
look at mountains because there's
something that taps into that like like
it's it's hard to not feel some humility
when you're looking at a mountain that's
right it's hard to not feel some
humility when you're watching a
beautiful sunset on the side of a
[__] you know bridge that was built
2000 years ago when you're in italy
you're uh places like that what do you
think they've figured out that americans
haven't they're a lot they're an older
society they're a much different society
understood like the boy [__] had a
time sure and
and then they got
rid of boy [__] yes this is this is
some real [__] you want to know some
real for sure we all
we all if we live long enough become
bigots even the most progressive version
that's right so like italy greek roman
empire early antiquity everybody's boy
[__] everybody has a little [__]
apprentice they [__] them that's right
catholicism comes in
and cuts it out
they go hey we gotta stop [__]
animals stop [__] boys they got these
[__] brothels that are in like
pompeii that are preserved well they got
the menu up there there's [__]
animals there's kids there's whatever
you [__] want right catholicism comes
in and then goes chill the [__] out
right
now fast forward
two thousand years right catholic
catholics are the boy [__] right and
it's like
i wonder if there's like historian
priests that are like
do you know how many boys would be
[__] if it wasn't for us right like we
cut this whole [__] out glee we decided
let us do it it got too far let us give
us a little let us run let us let's let
us run it it's like with the union
spillage what i never like you know i
sometimes i doubt religion but yeah
beautifully explained it
as it needed it stopped right it was it
got too far it was too free but then
also the catholic church was like let us
just do it a little
wouldn't you rather little than a lot
that's better a little or a lot a little
two boys [__] or 2 000 which do you
choose probably two
you know
those are the trouble if those are the
choices and by the way let me switch it
whatever you're honestly what an honest
election
what an honest election you walk in
there and they go biden a hundred
thousand children [__] let's go to the
next guy sixty-five thousand children
and you gotta go oh my god sixty-five
thousand but then you have to look at
your wife and go but this guy's not
raising the gas tax she goes but it's
another thirty thousand boys being
[__] and it's like he goes yeah but
you know how much the gas tax is yeah
yeah but it is it is i don't drive a boy
isn't that interesting that for whatever
reason that's like what's run
that's what's run
society for so long what is catholicism
boy [__] boy [__] it's weird that
that
like pedophilia has become you know
what's the weirdest yeah is you weren't
gay till you were 25 well i was gay with
the [__] balls oh so you did boy [__]
no no i was gay when i was younger but i
came out of the closet at 25. i acted on
it in my late teens early 20s okay so
you got a little piece of like what what
everybody has wanted so bad for years
well for decades for centuries no i was
under age i was of age oh so when you
were 18. yeah i was a va i wasn't
humiliated you could have had like a
like legal years but i don't think
that's what they want i don't think it's
boys [__] boy it's the older people
[__] the boy you're probably right
yeah it's that you're probably right
yeah it could have something to do with
the power dynamic right and not actual
like enjoyment no it's definitely
enjoyment but i think it's like it's
like i think it's part of like the thing
of like well we can do anything else so
we're a lot we've been able to do
everything else we've had orgies we've
had hookers we've had this we've had
that what's next so
do you think human beings need a
governor and by governor i mean the car
version not like the political version
the thing that stops your car from going
300 miles per hour
yes a bumper yes we've never we've never
replaced religion
with anything
um that has fulfilled people one of the
biggest problems i think with society
now is that technology is clearly our
new religion
everybody believes it money's a religion
well yeah but technology now every
everything's so plugged into the
technology that money is becoming
just part of technology when you say
technology like social currency you mean
like likes i mean like well i mean like
basically the entire
um
interdependent world that we've created
where what dictates our behavior does
technology dictate it or does it uh
acquiring resources dictated that's well
i think technology now is the way to
acquire resources because you can't get
a job without some type of profile yeah
you can't get a bank account you can't
get a whatever um so because we we all
have to buy into that system
um it becomes like a religion there's
sacraments there's things like that and
i don't think that religion is
fulfilling to people i think it it's
because it says nothing about your soul
says nothing about the afterlife right
it says nothing about uh how you should
treat other people it says nothing about
these cosmic questions it just says a
lot about how to
serve yourself yeah practically get by
and serve yourself and that's why we
have you know people have made this
point a million times whether you're on
the far left or the far right these are
all just belief systems it's religion
it's a way to get through life yeah and
to me it's like i i
i think that like
you know we need to figure out
in our society if we can stay human
if there's a value to it or should we
speed up
just getting rid of this skin suit and
then and and then between the elon thing
yeah i mean because it there's an
inevitability to it not in our lifetime
but like like
can we
stay human beings yeah or are we just
gonna eventually go [__] it
let's just take out all the
imperfections and upload our
consciousness and just become the sci-fi
movie yeah maybe that maybe that happens
i don't know yeah i guess that
maybe that happens or maybe we have
another like
you know middle ages and everything goes
back to zero so that could be happening
that kind of that's what i think has
probably happened probably on the verge
of many times we're maybe on the cusp of
going right back to the dark ages i
really believe that that has happened
multiple times in human history